cette photo a été prise cet été dont
béni kabangu une sa poule venait tout
juste de gradué de l'école secondaire de
la pointe-aux-trembles à montréal
[Musique]
photo là son père raconte qu'il était en
forme
quand il a commencé à faire de la fièvre
il y a quelques semaines la famille il a
emmené à l'hôpital pierre le gardeur à
terrebonne s'est elle a fait de la 3ème
semaine que la chose à l'hôpital dont
bini est décédé dimanche
il n'avait que 19 ans ce qui en fait la
plus jeune victime de la coved 19 au
québec
la deuxième de moins de 20 ans au canada
il était très en forme il était très en
forme il est en très bonne santé en tout
cas je ne crois pas qu'il ait eu des
antécédents de santé
celui qui était son entraîneur de soccer
jusqu'à l'an dernier le décrit lui aussi
comme un jeune homme très sportif et
surtout bienveillant effacé il faisait
passer l'équipe en premier tout le temps
c'est vraiment c'est un très bon garçon
c'était vraiment un garçon génial un nom
je peux dire c'est vraiment et non je
m'appelle de sa peau est gérée dicko
kinshasa dans cette vidéo tournée en
il raconte qu'il est arrivé au pays avec
sa famille en 2015
il participait alors un programme du
centre d'histoire de montréal pour
valoriser le parcours de jeunes
immigrants des souvenirs pour ne pas
obérer la culture de leur pays au monde
cet ami qui a grandi avec lui en rdc et
qui le considère comme un frère est
l'une des nombreuses personnes qui ont
participé à une campagne de sociaux
financement au profit de la famille
alors dominique a bon goût de sap ou
avait-il un problème de santé qu'il
rendait plus vulnérables à la coved 19
si oui il n'était pas connu disent ses
proches
le ministère de la santé ne peut pas
nous en dire davantage sur ce cas précis
mais affirme que les jeunes qui meurent
du virus de façon générale présente des
comorbidités
ici sébastien desrosiers radio canada
morrell